- [Instructor] Let's talk a little bit
about arteries and veins
and the roles they play
in the circulatory system.
So I want you to pause this video
and first think to yourself,
Do you have a sense of what
arteries and veins are?
Well one idea behind arteries and veins
are that well, in most of these drawings,
arteries are drawn in red,
and I even made the
artery word here in red.
And veins are drawn in blue.
And so maybe that represents
how much oxygen they have.
And so one possible explanation is that
arteries carry oxygenated blood,
oxygenated, oxygenated blood,
while veins carry deoxygenated blood.
So blood that has less oxygen now.
Now this is actually incorrect.
It is, many times, the case that arteries
are the ones carrying oxygenated blood
and veins are carrying
the deoxygenated blood.
But as we will see, this
is not always the case.
And since we're already
talking about oxygenated blood
and deoxygenated blood and
the colors red and blue,
it's worth addressing
another misconception.
Many times it is said that
deoxygenated blood looks blue,
and the reason why people believe that
is if you look at your
wrist and you're able to see
some of the vessels in there,
you will see some blue vessels.
And those, or at least they look blue
when you're looking from
the outside of your skin.
And those, indeed, are veins.
And so that's where the
misconception has come from,
that veins, which, in your arm,
are carrying deoxygenated blood.
That that deoxygenated blood is blue.
It turns out that it is not blue.
It is just a deeper red.
And the reason why the veins look blue
is because of the optics of
light going through your skin
and then seeing the outside of the veins
and then reflecting back.
That is not the color of the actual blood.
So so far I have not given
you a clear definition
of what arteries versus veins are.
A better definition, so
let me cross these two out,
are that arteries carry
blood away from the heart.
Away from the heart.
And veins carry blood towards the heart.
Towards the heart.
And I can get a zoomed in
image of the heart right here
and that will make it
a little bit clearer.
And you can also see,
or we're about to see,
why this first definition,
or this first distinction
between arteries and veins
does not always hold.
So let's just imagine
some blood that is being
pumped away from the heart.
So right when it gets
pumped away from the heart,
it'll be right over here.
It gets pumped through the aorta,
and you can see the aorta branches,
so some blood can go up towards your head,
and if it didn't, you
would pass out and die.
And then a lot of the blood goes down
towards the rest of your body.
And that, indeed, is the
most oxygenated blood.
And so it'll flow through your body.
And these arteries will
keep branching and branching
into smaller vessels,
all the way until they form
these very small branches.
And it's that place, especially,
where they will lose a lot of their oxygen
to the fluid and the cells around them.
And then the blood is less oxygenated.
And then even though
deoxygenated blood is not blue,
it often gets depicted as
blue in a lot of diagrams.
So I will do the same.
And these vessels start
building into your veins.
And these really small
vessels that really bridge
between arteries and veins,
where a lot of the gas and
nutrient exchange occurs,
these are called capillaries.
And so after going
through the capillaries,
the blood will then come back to the heart
and now it's coming towards
the heart through the veins.
It comes into the right atrium,
then the right ventricle.
Then that gets pumped towards the lungs.
And this is the exception
to the first incorrect
definition of arteries and
veins that we looked at.
This right over here, is an artery.
Even though it's carrying less oxygenated
or deoxygenated blood,
it's an artery because it's carrying blood
away from the heart.
But in this case, it's not carrying it to
the rest of the body,
it is carrying it to the lungs.
That is why it is called
the pulmonary artery,
even though it's carrying
less oxygenated blood.
So that it goes to the lungs and then,
in the lungs, there's more
gas exchange that occurs.
The blood gets oxygenated
and then it comes back
to the heart.
And so it comes back to
the heart in these vessels
right over here,
and that even though these are carrying
highly oxygenated blood,
these are considered veins
because they're carrying blood
towards the heart.
So these are pulmonary veins.
And then the cycle starts again.
The pulmonary veins bring
the oxygenated blood
into the left atrium
and the left ventricle,
and then that pumps it
to the rest of the body
to the aorta, for your
systemic circulation.
You have your pulmonary circulation,
which circulates the blood to,
through and from the lungs.
And you have your systemic circulation,
which takes the blood to and
from the rest of the body.
So now that we have this main distinction
between arteries and veins,
what are some other interesting things
that we know about it?
Well one thing to keep in mind is that
since arteries are being
pumped directly by the heart
towards the rest of the body,
they have high pressure.
I'll write that in caps.
High pressure.
And so if you were to have
an accident of some type,
which you do not want to have,
and you were to
accidentally cut an artery,
because of that high pressure,
it would actually spurt blood,
a lot more than if you were to cut a vein.
And most of the times where you get a cut,
you're really just cutting capillaries.
Like if you were to prick your finger,
it's usually a series of
capillaries that get cut,
and that's why the blood would
come out very very slowly.
Now if arteries are high
pressure, veins are low pressure.
Low, low pressure.
And one way to think about it is
the arteries, the blood
is being pumped directly
by the heart.
But then once it goes
through the capillaries
and comes back through the veins,
it's kind of sluggishly making
its way back to the heart.
It's not being directly pumped.
And that's why in veins,
because you don't have that
high pressure to bring
everything back to the heart,
you have these valves that make
sure that for the most part,
the blood is going in one direction.
I'm going to draw the
blood in red in the veins,
just so we don't keep going
with that misconception,
that blood in the veins is blue somehow.
Now related to the fact that
the blood in the arteries
is under higher pressure,
in order to transport
a fixed volume of blood
in a certain amount of
time, you need less volume.
And so that's why arteries are low volume.
And on the other hand,
veins are high volume.
And to appreciate the difference,
the blood volume in arteries
are only approximately
15% of the entire blood
volume in your body,
while the blood volume in
veins are closer to 65%,
approximately 65%.
And if you're wondering where
the rest of the blood is,
about five percent is in capillaries,
five percent is in your heart,
and about 10% is in your lungs.
So I will leave you there.
The big take away:
arteries are the vessels
that take blood away from the heart.
Veins are the vessels that
take blood towards the heart.